sprenger über oben ohne auf dem
wasserspielplatz anstößig oder als ich
irgendwie nicht oder doch das ist jetzt
der botenstoff von berlin tritt teuer
wären richtig ja eine frau hat da oben
ohne geplant an der platte in berlin die
polizei ist angekommen sie aber die frau
will sich immer noch nichts über ziehen
und jetzt kommt's zum busen prozess
heute vom landgericht in berlin ganz
genau das gericht das sich mit der frage
beschäftigt oben ohne oder oben mit
schwierige frage bei uns die hamburger
spd politikerin
paulina reinecke
lohnt es sich vor für oben ohne wirklich
jetzt bis vor gericht zu ziehen so
wichtiges thema
also ich bin absolut die richtige
entscheidung bei den damen ja auch
selber gesagt hat sie hat sich an der
stelle diskriminiert gefühlt
und dann ist natürlich ein richtiger
schritt hierzu sagen ich gehe gegen
diese diskriminierung von ihnen dann
auch mit rechtlichen schritten
lassen sie mir noch mal ganz kurz
verstehen warum das eine diskriminierung
ist wenn sie dort plant irgendwie auf
diesem wasserspielplatz oder freibad
ähnlichen gelände dort sie will oben
ohne tragen und darf das nicht warum ist
das der diskriminierung also ich gehe
jetzt an der stelle einfach davon aus
dass männer an der stelle eben genauso
oben ohne rum laufen durften sich ohne
titel gezeigt haben und dass da eben
nicht als anstößig oder falsch gegolten
hat und da er nicht die polizei gerufen
wurde und nur gemacht wird weil sie eine
frau ist und weil da die brüste als
etwas anderes an der stelle an gesehen
wurden und dann etwas anstößiges und
system dann an diskriminierung aufgrund
ihrer äußerlichen merkmale dass sie sich
da anders behalten muss als die männer
das gleichzeitig tun müssen also beim
thema frauen bin ich ja ganz bei ihnen
aber ich muss sagen es gibt doch jetzt
unter uns schon einen unterschied
zwischen einem busen einer weiblichen
brust und an wenigen brust oder sind wir
alle gleich
also es gibt äußerlichen unterschiede
machen nicht sagen müssen wir das an der
größe müssen wir das in der form bei da
sind männer teilweise nicht so weit
hinter uns kann man sagen und das was
daraus gemacht wird dass es eben sexuell
angesehen 87 deutlich gemacht dass eine
sexualisierung der von der frau an der
stelle gar nicht gewinnspiels jetzt
jedoch nicht ausgezogen um angeguckt zu
werden in sexuell angesehen zu werden
das ist etwas was andere leute daraus
machen und das ist ebenfalls wenn ich
mich ausziehen möchte ich genauso
angeschaut werden wenn man an der
schlange schaffen ich wundere mich ein
bisschen dass so ein busen soft dann
tatsächlich vor gericht landen kann aber
ich machen angebot euch beiden
vielleicht auch patricia zusammen
kompromiss heißt es bei ihnen frau rücke
gab es schonmal
gelegenheiten oder momente wo sie sich
belästigt gefühlt haben durch einen
männlichen freien oberkörper zum
beispiel im freibad
also tatsächlich nicht belästigt indem
sie natürlich mich eher wenn es daneben
anstellen ist wie wo ist bahn innenstadt
wo auch teilweise keine konsequenzen
kommt unangenehm viele menschen ist das
auf einmal halt nach dem menschen
herumlaufen und darf und ich sieht man
eben diese unterscheidung zwischen den
körpern gemacht würden dafür müssen
einfach einheitliche regeln gucken dass
wir sagen an manchen stellen dürfen uns
nackt oder nackter zeigen wie im freibad
und am strand kein problem ist und es
gibt orte an die wir uns eben nicht egal
ob männlich oder weiblich oder oben ohne
zeigen also ich muss sagen ich bin ich
bin da beim thema zum beispiel stillen
in der öffentlichkeit volle kanne bei
ihnen und muss sagen ich verstehe ich
jetzt wirklich nicht warum jemand sätze
sagt wie und ein ziel hätte mir da ihren
busen ins gesicht ich finde aber doch
das weibliche brüste auch eine
sexualisierte haben sie auch selber
gesagt ein sexualisiertes bild irgendwie
bieten sollen wir uns davon quasi
komplett verabschieden 7 gesagt auch für
dich so recht das haben wir
gesellschaftlich etabliert sondern es
einfach abschaffen sollte einfach sagen
und blick auf nackte frauen brüste ist
quasi genau so neutral wie ein blick auf
den männeroberkörper
also es darf natürlich sexualisiert sein
wenn es einvernehmlich ist und
beispielsweise nur ein paar mal fahre
ich daheim bin oder auch in anderen
situationen muss eben erwünscht oder
gedrückt ist darf natürlich jedes
körperteil der sexuell oder davon
sexuellen reiz haben aber genau dieses
problem ja eben eine frau in der
öffentlichkeit stellt hat sie immer auch
das problem dass sie oft sechs angemacht
wird männern weil da eben nicht diese
entscheidung stattfinden damals mir den
angehen dass eine frau selber
entscheiden dürfen welchen situationen
sie sexuell ist und den wir ja nicht
dass sie sich eben ausziehen kann ohne
dass sie eben gleich sexuell
angesprochen wird danke paulina eine
krücke zu diesem busen zoff hier gerade
vom gericht vom landgericht in berlin
danke
der ist eine interessante diskussion wir
werden hier natürlich diese diskussion
auch weiter verfolgen auch vor allem wie
das ganze natürlich vor gericht aus geht
erfahren sie hier natürlich
[Musik]